DANA VIGUE: When I
enrolled in this course,
I expected it to be
a traditional one
professor, large population
of students sort of dynamic
in a seminar style.
But what I found was
that we had half a dozen
different professors
or more over the course
of the semester.
And I've never been in a
class in that style before.
So it was a new
environment for learning.
And I wasn't sure how what we
learned in class day to day
would be able to carry
over in a cohesive way
as we switched
lecturers, but what
I found was that a
common thread was woven
throughout the course
of the semester,
and that thread drew from
diverse individuals who
have expertise in
diverse fields of study,
and who have used that
expertise in diverse ways
to work and collaborate with,
again, diverse groups of people
throughout the world.
And I think that ended up being
the central theme of the class,
that the black
experience, you know,
this sort of overused phrase
that we might hear just
as colloquially is
monolithic compared
to the diversity of
experiences that this class was
able to demonstrate
to each of us.
ELENA ALBERTI:
Bouncing off of that,
I think something that
was also interesting
was not only the multitude
of voices in the professors,
but the multitude of different
voices within the student
population.
When we were
introducing ourselves,
I think most of us
are different majors,
and we also come from
different backgrounds
and different ethnicities
and different sexualities
and genders.
And I think having
such a group discussion
with different
professors allows you
to get a lot of
different perspectives,
not only from the
professorial side,
but from the student experience
and what you're experiencing
here as different individuals.
LORRAINE WONG: Yeah,
I really appreciated
the different courses of
everyone in the class,
but also in the professors,
so some of our guest lecturers
were from women's and gender
studies, or CMS, which
is comparative media
studies, writing, literature,
so we had all these different
perspectives, like Fox
Harrell's Phantasms and the
virtual reality project,
to Professor Helen Elaine
Lee's writing workshops,
and when we had to delve deep
into what our parents taught us
and how we were raised,
and all these things.
And I think each of them
brought such important facets
to the conversation
that we could explore
within ourselves and
within the outer world,
and how black matters isn't just
anthropology or just history
or something, but it's all of
these different things, which
is why it's so important
to the real engagement.
COLIN GODWIN: Yeah, it was
like each speaker brought
a different view on emancipatory
literacy to the class,
and just showed us
the different ways
we could dissect
everything we see.
ELENA ALBERTI: Also,
I think hearing
from the different professors
also, as a sophomore,
opens me up to taking more
classes in different areas.
I didn't realize how many
actual parts go into this class,
because I remember when I
was looking through the class
list it's like, oh
yeah, this counts
for CI-H, HASS-A,
like everything.
And I was like, why?
And then you realize, with
all the different professors.